but i know more people than that that
have been canceled
literally cancelled their careers have
been cancelled due to
um you know uh
cancer culture things that had to do
with real serious stuff like
underage girls and stuff like that and
there
you know last year was a lot of
stand-ups just got
and actors i mean look what happened i
mean it was
it's um and a lot of it
had no court trial but it was like it
was done and done
you know twitter can destroy you you can
destroy yourself on twitter
right i could write a tweet right now
that could literally
shut me down right now it's so easy
isn't that something and i did a joke in
in 1984 on this clip
this on this rodney dangerfield special
and i was 26 years old and i had a joke
and i
i apologized for it on posting on
instagram because they said you can
cancel me for this and the joke was
um i never got to go to camp because my
mom thought i'd get embarrassed
undressing in front of little boys but i
kind of like it now
and then i would go no that's not true i
like it a lot no that's not true i'm not
a senator
so at that time some senator had been
caught with a
minor so that's not a joke i could do
right now
and yet if i tried to do something like
that
i would tee it up for five minutes then
you get you know
a ten-second laugh and then people wince
and then you gotta do another three
minutes to dig out of that
so what's the point that's nice but the
point of the joke if you're
smart enough or not even that smart is
that you're getting to the point of the
senator you're almost speaking from them
you're not saying
you would do this you're like you know i
did say
in that joke that i liked getting
undressed in front of little boys now
but then i would say that's not true so
what does it leave you with it leaves
you with something where there are so
many heinous things that have happened
since
from the priesthood to boy scouts who
thought the boy scouts would go through
this you know
it's it's just uh you know when your
group leader says tie a slip knot on my
penis jimmy
you know that's not that's not what
you're in there for
um now that could get me canceled
because it's tragic
yeah so i'd like to apologize right now
i what happens is from my point of view
for me
is when i make a dark joke that is about
the worst
thing it's my way there's two options
i either was three i shut up
which would be what i should have done i
make the joke
and then have to explain the context of
it
or i simply do a public service
announcement for
can you believe this is happening and
that this that young people need to be
protected
and what a horrible horrible world we
live in where human beings could do this
to a child and that is a sin against god
that's the meaning of the joke that's
what i'm saying
but you know sarcasm satire
there's so much pain and so many people
have been hurt
it doesn't work anymore it will again
but maybe not on that level not when it
comes to sexual abuse and stuff
not it won't work on that level but
it's like john rickles doing his act
today it it wouldn't be the same because
he
was making fun of every nationality
every shade of skin
every religious person and he still
would do
anti-semitic self-loathing jokes which
is another problem
you know for people but he got out
uh just in time though i wish he was
alive because i was close with him and i
loved him so much
but you know people change
times change and people know what good
people
are i think you know a person that
professes
uh goodness and you can tell that
they're and they don't look at you
creepy while they're professing it
are basically you know i think noble at
heart i'd like to
think that people are are better than
they're being portrayed right
you